-How are you, John?
-Hi, Seth.
This is my little friend, Seth
and he wanted to meet you.
I hope that's all right.
-Oh, my goodness.
And what a delight to meet him
-What did you call me,
a comedy legend?
-I called you a comedy legend.
-No, I've been promoted.
I'm a comedy icon now.
-Oh, my goodness.
When did that happen?
-It happened last Friday,
which is why everybody doesn't
know about it yet.
But I am an icon.
-That's fantastic.
I mean, I'm assuming
that's like one of those thing
where the Queen knights yo
and there's
different orders of merit,
right?
-Well, it's not quite.
It is a small legislative
occasion in Parliament
when you get promoted.
The next stage for me is
national institution.
What do you, Seth? Are you
an icon or a legend, perhaps
-I think I -- you know,
I know I was an "up-and-comer"
for a long time.
-[ Laughs ]
-And now, I think the last
I've heard, I'm "established."
-Ah, very good.
-Yeah, it's not
a bad place to be.
-Now, Seth, you're very
important.
Seth, you're
very important to me.
-Well, it's a --
you know it --
-Because you're
the first writer...
-Well, thank you.
-...I've spoken to
about the book.
Because you were, what,
you were head writer
on "Saturday Night Live"
for how long?
-I've -- probably about
six or seven years
I think I held that job.
-Amazing!
So, what I said in the book,
did you recognize it
or do you have
a different process?
-Well, I mean, the one thing
I want to talk to you most about
is collaboration.
-Ah.
-Because you sort of
speak a lot about how
collaboration brought out
the best in your creativity.
-Yes, I think so.
If I always wrote with
Graham Chapman.
And I felt if I was writin
with Graham,
I would usually get somewher
that I wouldn't get on my own,
even if it was a result of
a set of misunderstandings
-You know, I was wondering -
you know, because one of the
things I should point out
about this book
is you believe that people
do have a creativity
unlocked in them.
Because I think a lot of peopl
might just think to themselves
"I'm not a creative person."
And one of the reasons
you point out in the book
is that creativity
is not ever really taught
in schools as a skill.
-No!
-It's not allowed
to develop early on.
-It's kind of amazing
that you can go through
a whole good
educational career
without anyone ever telling yo
about creativity.
It's astounding.
But that's just the way
we think.
And we accept it without reall
questioning it.
I mean, I had no idea that I had
any creative ability at al
because I got into Cambridge
on science.
And it's quite hard
to be creative
if you're studying science
unless you're Stephen Hawking,
you know?
-Yeah, you never want
to hear that you have
a very creative scientist.
[ Laughter ]
Although, I guess we can tak
some creative scientists
right now.
I shouldn't say that.
But let me ask this,
when did you --
because it was sort of later -
not later,
but you weren't
in your adolescence
when you realized that you
wanted to be a comedian.
What was the first time like
that you wrote comedy?
-Um, I wrote some sketches
at Cambridge.
I mean, I did one or two
"house entertainments,"
they were called at school
but it never occurred to m
I might finish up.
I came from the lower
middle class,
and everybody was either
a solicitor,
which is a lawyer that
doesn't appear in court,
or they became an accountant
or they ran a shop, you know
If you're Weston-super-Mare,
you're not going
to be a comedian
any more than you're
going to be a matador or,
you know, a pope.
It just isn't
on the radar screen.
But when I discovered I coul
make people laugh,
I never thought I'd go
into the profession.
But what's so lovely about
making people laugh
is that it's a good feeling.
It's a good feeling for you an
a good feeling for them, right
-And did you --
the first time --
because I certainly remember
those early times of havin
that rush of not just feelin
good because they're laughing,
but knowing that they were
feeling good as well.
Was that an immediate opiate
for you,
the idea of making people laugh?
-Yes. Yes.
It's a lovely feeling.
I mean, and I still get it
I went out on the stage
at the Acropolis in Athens
last November.
There were 4,000 people
stacked up on a stage
that people have been performing
on for 2,000 years.
And there's something abou
being on a stage
in front of an audience
or going out, you know,
and doing the opening
monologue.
It can be scary,
but it's so real.
There you are trying to make
people laugh.
-I think the Acropolis --
you definitely have to be
an icon to play the Acropolis.
-[ Laughs ]
-They don't --
-I'll have a word
with the House of Commons
this year
if I can get you promoted.
-Not a lot of --
not a lot of open mic nights
at the Acropolis.
[ Laughter ]
-That's funny.
So, listen, when you
read the book,
did you agree with
what I was saying?
Or do you find
that there were bits
that were not what
your process was?
-Well, one thing
I really agreed with,
it's I think very hard
to explain.
And I do want to talk to you
about the fact
that you have spent
a lot of time studying
the human mind as well,
is the very fact that we can b
creative unconsciously.
And --
-Yes.
-'Cause I think that
sometimes, you know,
when comedy comes out good
it looks as though
the mind had always
constructed it that way.
But you talk about the idea that
sometimes you'd hit problems
and all that it would take
to solve it
would be a good night's sleep.
-Yeah.
And I couldn't figure out
why a problem that I was unabl
to sort out at 10:00 at night,
and I could wake up
the next morning,
make a cup of coffee
and sit down,
and the solution,
in 90 seconds
I could see what to do,
and I couldn't think
what was the problem
the previous evening.
And I realized it was only
because my unconscious
was actually -- went on workin
while I was asleep.
And then I lost a script
I was writing with Graham,
and I knew he'd be
cross with me.
So I had to rewrite it out
by memory
to pretend I hadn't lost it.
And then I found the original,
and the one I had done
from memory was better.
It was more concise
and clever and tight.
It was a better bit of writing
But I hadn't been trying
to make it better.